can we all agree that a whole new world
is like the most romantic Disney song of
all time I mean a magical starlight
flight around the world beautiful and
then he mix in some of the best lyrics
of all time like when did you last let
your heart decide smooth as butter there
Aladdin soaring tumbling freewheeling
through an endless diamond sky gorgeous
poetry don't you dare close your eyes oh
what'd you say there let you know real
talk Aladdin maybe you don't need to be
a prince to get Jasmine maybe I don't
know you just stop interrupting your
beautiful love song with creepy threats
just saying hello Internet welcome to
film theory the YouTube equivalent of a
poo get my dirty paws and everything
that you don't want me touching and then
ruining it for everyone today we're
finally talking about Aladdin
indeed it is hot YouTube and tick tock
star Will Smith because with it being
the holidays I finally got around to
seeing The Fresh Prince get decked out
like a smurf to reboot Aladdin gotta be
honest there was a lot more screen time
dedicated to the genie crushing hard on
a human hand maid than I was expecting
she's going to get some punch myself
the reboot genuinely surprised me I did
not anticipate walking out of this movie
contemplating the physics of Jeannie
human relations glad we rebooted this
animated class to insert the clearly
important story thread
oh yeah and to also insert the fact that
jasmine is totally woke in this version
even though she was already the most
outspoken and independent princess from
the original animated era but you know
maybe that was too subtle or maybe the
audience was just distracted by her
outfit back then or something so now
we're gonna beat it over your head with
a song about being strong AF and having
a voice of your own which ironically
enough no one hears because it's a song
that's happening in your head womp womp
confused messaging is confusing but if
I'm being honest I really like this
movie definitely more than I expected
and definitely not as much as the
original kind of sums up my feelings
about most of these live-action remakes
except for the Jungle Book one which was
really awesome
anyway as you might have suspected
revisiting this movie also got me to
revisit all the old nitpicks people have
about the movies wishing system
specifically the nitpicks around
Aladdin's first wish to become a prince
I wish for you to make me a prince I
found it interesting that in both the
original 1993 version as well as the
better at not being racist but worse at
being entertaining live-action remake
that Aladdin's first wish ultimately
goes nowhere it's waste in both versions
of the story it just doesn't work sure
we get ourselves a delightful song and
dance number but both times jasmine is
fairly unimpressed in Aladdin has
eventually recognized to be the old
street rat he was from before which
honestly brings up some interesting
questions about how exactly genies
powers work but that's a theory for
another day now obviously Aladdin's
number one goal is to marry Princess
Jasmine and the law says that she can
only marry a prince and the genie can't
make people fall in love so I get where
Aladdin's coming from with this wish it
is the best workaround that Aladdin can
think of but clearly it doesn't work so
that begs the question what should
Aladdin have done given the rules that
the film is established for its own
universe and also the historical /
political system in which the movie set
what would have been the best wish
Aladdin could have made to marry jasmine
and live happily ever
after in only one wish which then leaves
two others left for I don't know
whatever he wants a lifetime supply of
classic 90s snack foods 3d Doritos you
were so gnarly and you are so dead
before your time so let's not waste any
more time
mr. Aladdin sir what should your one
wish be let's do some research get
creatively never had a theory like me in
order to give a land the best advice
possible we need to first narrow down
where the events of the movie are taking
place so we can at least give him some
insight into the political system that
we're dealing with because guess what
Agrabah doesn't really exist now
obviously we're dealing with the
Sultanate he is the Sultan but what
exactly does being the Sultan mean well
a Sultanate is really just a term for
any region ruled by a leader who bears
the Islamic title of Sultan sultanates
have been found historically from Turkey
all the way to Indonesia which as you
can imagine creates a huge problem for
us we are talking about a massive area
of the globe as such it should come as
no surprise that different sultanates
are gonna have themselves different
rules different structures different
levels of intermingling between religion
and politics as such it's extremely
important to nail down agra bus location
so that we can give Aladdin accurate and
regionally specific advice looking for
us we do get some clues from the movies
as to where our fictional setting might
really exist some people are quick to
point out the design of the Sultan's
palace is awfully reminiscent of the Taj
Mahal which once you know it is located
in Agra India and Agra sounds a whole
lot like Agrabah so many people conclude
that Agrabah must be somewhere in India
but I don't really think that's our best
conclusion at the beginning of the
animated Aladdin the merchant mentions
Agra bus relation to the river Jordan
the Jordan River is just off the
Mediterranean Sea in modern-day Syria
Israel and unsurprisingly Jordan
additionally the song Arabian Nights
strongly implies that we're in Arabia
which historically referred to what's
now Saudi Arabia and the surrounding
countries so if we're in what's
historically known as Arabia and we have
ourselves some proximity to the river
Jordan then Agrabah is most likely part
of the
Ottoman Empire which sprawled from
Turkey through much of the Middle East
from the 14th century until the early
1900s
still a massive area but much more
targeted than we were before so if we
accept that Agrabah somewhere in the
ottoman empire is it good for Aladdin to
wish to become a prince well it depends
on what you mean by Prince exactly
strictly speaking a prince in this form
of government would literally be the son
of the Sultan so if his goal is to marry
the daughter of a sultan let's be sure
to specify that he wants to be a foreign
prince
otherwise that prankster genie might
fulfill on his wish to the letter and
marrying Jasmine might get super awkward
super quickly depending on how the genie
chooses to fulfill on that wish so
Aladdin to make sure that his wishes
airtight wishes to become a foreign
prince that's the fix then right not
really in the very earliest days of the
Ottoman Empire marriages with foreign
powers were tactical but Aladdin is
allegedly the prince of a place so small
and unimportant that Jasmine's never
heard of it before
she can't even find it on a map as such
it's highly unlikely that the Sultan
would be willing to marry her off to
such a minor figure in the greater
political scheme of things that said
there is another consideration here the
Ottoman Empire was divided into
provinces called a ohlet's which are
further divided into districts called
son jocks and while the government of
these provinces and districts were not
hereditary meaning that they shouldn't
have had princes per se many of the son
jocks were established to serve
Lordships that had existed before the
territory was a part of the Empire
therefore if Aladdin made himself part
of the elite class of one of the son
jocks that may technically make him a
quote-unquote Prince eligible to marry
jasmine the problem here though is well
he might be eligible at that point he
wouldn't be very special there were
hundreds upon hundreds of son jocks
throughout the Empire so again it's
unlikely that any title relating to that
sanjak is gonna get in much respect in
Agrabah it would be like rolling into
Washington DC and demanding respect
because you're the member of a City
Council of a small town in Montana they
probably never heard you they probably
don't care probably gonna send you back
to your herd a buffalo
so Aladdin's wish to be a prince isn't a
very good one whether you're
interpreting that to mean that he'd have
to be related to jasmine gross or
a small player in a very local
government so that pretty much sums up
why the wish he made wouldn't really
work the way he made it which leads us
to the question what should a LED and
have wished for here well since the
Sultan made the law in the first place
why not skip being a prince and go
directly to the top wish to become the
Sultan himself and he could presumably
change the law and allow Jasmine to
marry whomever she wanted so what if
Aladdin had wished himself to be a
sultan unfortunately there are two
pretty big problems here too the first
is that Genie wish-granting doesn't seem
to magically affect everyone involved in
that wish so that they just
automatically go along with what the
wish was for Jafar winds up learning
this the hard way in the live-action
Aladdin remake when he himself wishes to
be Sultan and starts ordering around the
imperial guard how came you obey the
Sultan so you obey me now and then fast
forward one Jasmine speech later and he
suddenly got a mutiny on his hands
my princess let's think this through the
Imperial Guard basically just decides
whom they want to follow regardless of
who actually holds the title of Sultan
and if they're willing to turn on the
Grand Vizier closest adviser to the
Sultan do we really think that they
would have respected Aladdin's authority
if he just showed up and magically made
himself the Sultan that he would have
probably had him executed for trying to
usurp the throne and that's a whole mess
that Allen doesn't want to get himself
mixed up in the Ottoman Empire wasn't
exactly shy about committing executions
and well let's just say that the quality
of your execution could vary a lot if
you were lucky you got yourself a quick
and pleasant way to die like being
strangled to death by someone's bare
hands if you were unlucky you might get
yourself hung from a meat hook Chainsaw
Massacre style the Ottoman Empire did
not mess around and that's not all let's
assume that the Imperial Guard and the
rest of the government was okay with
Aladdin living as the usurping Sultan
even if they were okay with it other
people definitely wouldn't be you see
succession in the Ottoman Empire was
often a pretty messy business when a
Sultan died any of his sons who wanted
to claim the throne which spoiler alert
was all the sons conducted a sort of
ancient fortnight a Battle Royale in
which the last one standing was the new
Sultan but matpat Aladdin wouldn't have
to worry about that because the Sultan's
only child was jasmine
you're absolutely right but it doesn't
mean that he's out of the woods just yet
and it's later years the Ottoman Empire
practiced what's called agentic
succession meaning that the eldest
living male in the dynasty would take
over when the Sultan died so if the
Sultan had himself a brother or a male
cousin or some crusty old uncle any of
those would likely have had a similarly
strong claim to the throne and could
have tackled a Lannon and trust me we
took the throne that someone else wanted
in the Ottoman Empire you were gonna
have yourself a bad time assassinations
happened all the time in this culture
now there are lots of assassination
stories from this period in history but
my personal favorite is Sultan Osman ii
who was assassinated by a guy called get
this hellevang the oil wrestler no wait
my friends there's more to this story
you see the method of death in this
assassination it's officially listed as
quote compression of the testicles Wow
just so many questions there Pella
Vaughn long story short Lana's gonna
have himself a lot of problems if he
wishes to become the Sultan the nicest
of which is that everyone ignores him
and the worst of which is that someone
is gonna come and squeeze his magic lamp
so hard that his diamonds pop out of the
rough all right so it's gonna be hard
for Al and hop into this line of
succession without either getting
himself ignored if he shoots too low or
killed if he shoots too high so what if
he just gets creative and breaks the
system outright what if Al and just
wishes Agra bus stop being a Sultanate
and that would get rid of the rule that
prevents him from marrying jasmine right
well it would but then it would open up
a whole new set of problems for him for
commoners during the Ottoman Empire
young men and women had zero say in whom
they got to marry it was really just an
arrangement brokered by the two sets of
parents Aladdin has himself no parents
around to help him even approach the
situation and we know that his long-lost
father is it gonna be getting involved
in his life until he needs help finding
the ultimate treasure hashtag
straight-to-video sequel so Aladdin has
himself an uphill battle he somehow
needs to get the law changed without
altering Agrabah social order or
ruffling the feathers of those in charge
by creating a successional crisis so
when you actually look at a Latin
situation it's pretty darn complex he
has one wish to get Jasmine to marry him
but most of those wishes
either gonna be a waste like him asking
to become a prince or worse he wishes
something that winds up getting him
executed but there is a solution here
there is actually one wish that
practically guarantees him Jasmine's
hand in marriage
Aladdin should wish for jasmine to
become the Sultan after their
flirtatious meeting in the market
Jasmine already has the hots for Aladdin
certainly much more so than any of her
other suitors like that weird blonde
prince guy from the live-action movies
so she would be incentivized to do away
with the law that states that she has to
marry a prince if she were the Sultan
that's totally within her right to do as
Sultan's effectively answer to no one
during the Ottoman Empire
so that box gets itself a big checkmark
next question would this create the same
crisis of succession as if Aladdin
became the Sultan well it's not likely
remember that when Jafar names himself
the Sultan it takes Jasmine less than 5
minutes to turn the Imperial Guard to
her side my princess
forgive me guards arrest the Vizier the
Sultan himself wouldn't seem to put up
too much of a fight either because he
literally gives up control of Agra but
to her at the end of the live-action
remake and hey why shouldn't she rule
she's charismatic enough to lead she has
Agra bus best interests at heart plus
she has herself a pet tiger and she
likes to study maps but I'm sure you're
all thinking one thing here would the
Ottoman Empire have been ready to accept
a female as Sultan here's the twist
yeah actually they would in the 16th and
17th centuries the Ottoman Empire had
what's called the Sultanate of women in
which the wives and mothers of the
Sultan had themselves great political
and social power while running the
day-to-day operations of Empire and yes
there are instances in history of female
Sultan's or sultanas
there's even an instance where one Razia
al Din refused the title Sultana in the
13th century because she didn't want her
title to be distinct from a man's
there's even some occasions in history
in which a female Sultan ruled without
connection to a male Sultan if Aladdin
really wants the best chance at being
with jasmine in one wish and not setting
everyone against him his best bet is not
to wish for his own power but to wish
for Jasmine to finally get hers and
ironically enough it would get that
strong female theme across way more
effectively than any imaginary power
ballad ever
could but hey that's just a theory ah
film theory and you want your wish
granted well rub that magic subscribe
button so all your wishes come true
provided your wishes to wish for more
theories about your favorite film TV and
YouTube series or maybe your wishes to
help us get that diamond play button
which case thank you for helping to
grant that wish my wish to Robert Robert
don't you dare close your eyes
wow that those it's wow that is that is
disturbing I apologize for that one